Well, well, well, good morning, church.
Morning. It's e it's evening. Today's been a long day.
It's been a long day.
I screeched in here at the very last second.
Thank you, Neil, for accommodating me.
And, uh, great to see each of you.
I saw Mike way there in the back.
My vision is still good enough to see you.
So good to see you, Mike. And, uh,
so Wednesday nights are a special time.
Uh, you're, you're the core of the church,
so thank you for coming tonight.
Thank you for your commitment, uh, to the church.
Keep coming. Uh, my name is Ryan Whitaker,
and I've had the, the joy of, uh, serving as one
of your elders now for the last couple years.
And, uh, I really, um, enjoy that.
Uh, just a little bit about myself.
I'm gratefully married to Lindsey for 22 years now,
and we have four kids, uh, from 18 all the way down
to age 11.
And so we've been at Henderson Hills now for about 15 years,
which, uh, blows my mind how fast time flies.
And I'll never forget that day that we, uh,
first visited here.
The very first person that we met was Wally Weaver.
And if you know Wally, you know that he has this huge smile,
this huge welcoming smile, and he greeted us
and showed us to a seat.
And we sat, uh, way in the very back on that,
uh, that column of chairs there, the very back row.
And I'll never forget, I'll never forget that day, um,
because we had been looking for churches
and had visited quite a few churches.
And, um, what we sat under that day, 15 years ago
was, uh, just faithful biblical teaching
from God's word and God centered worship.
And I'll never forget it.
Also, uh, we were worshiping
and, uh, I looked over at Lindsay
and she had, uh, tears streaming down her face,
and I had tears streaming down my face.
And, uh, it was, it was then that we knew that we were home,
and I'll never forget that.
Um, so, uh, you know, as,
as I look back through my time at different churches over my
life, uh, I spent most of my years growing up in under a,
a Baptist church in Irving, Texas.
And, um, past that, I had,
I had a couple years at a Bible church toward
the end of high school.
And then in college, I, I, God led me to a church
that I, I really count
as a pivotal point in my faith journey
that if I hadn't landed there,
who knows where I would've landed.
Um, and so I, I spent four years at a very faithful
biblical Baptist church in Waco, Texas.
And then following college, I, I landed at,
with Lindsay a a Nazarene church.
And so we spent time, uh, nine years in,
in a Nazarene denomination church, uh,
before we, uh, uh,
and this is a little bit of a spoiler
for this coming weekend's teaching,
but it was, it was during that time in a non reformed church
that, uh, scripture really came alive to me.
And I couldn't help
but see some of the reformed teachings in scripture
that led us to here.
And so that's been some of my, uh,
journey, uh, through churches.
And so, I, I'm just curious here.
I can't see too well because of the lights,
but, uh, how many of you, by a show of hands,
have a Baptist upbringing?
Okay, so a good, good number of you.
Uh, what about Presbyterian? Any Presbyterian? Okay.
What about Lutheran?
A couple of you And Nazarene. Any Nazarene.
All right. And assembly of God. Okay, great. Great.
Uh, Catholic. Any Catholic upbringing? Okay.
Uh, Bible church, or just kind of a loosely Good. Good.
All right. And, uh, I'm curious,
how many people in a year have only
experienced Henderson Hills?
Okay, that's great. That's great.
Well, tonight we are looking at ecclesiology
or the study of the church.
Now, ecclesiology is the doctrine of the church.
And so on Sundays, John has been walking us
through a series called First Things First,
and this is talking about the core essential doctrines of
the church, uh, and our faith.
And so what we, uh, we're onto now, he's, he's,
we're moving on to what we would call secondary issues.
And these are what he sees as the smaller rocks.
And these are things that believers can differ on and,
and still, uh, still call brothers and sisters.
But it, it necessarily in some ways creates different
churches and different denominations.
And so, ecclesiology
or what makes a church a church is very,
is very much something that causes new churches
and denominations to form also.
And so, really, it's a tug of war, right?
It, it's a tug of war, um,
because we all want to be unified, right?
Unity is a good and glorious thing. And we also want purity.
We also want purity. We want purity in theology.
We want purity in doctrine.
We want purity in Phil, Phil, uh, Phil, uh,
philosophy, how we do ministry.
We want to be doing things in a pure way that aligns
with scripture, but we don't see it all the same way.
So, uh, it's a tug of war between purity
and unity
because, uh, we can be fully
united if we don't care about what we believe.
Okay? And on the opposite side, if we expect everyone
to believe every single detail of what we believe, then,
um, how many people would we have in our church?
If, if everybody believed exactly what we believed?
Well, it would be a church of exactly one person, it's you.
And that isn't a church. That isn't a church.
So we approach this tug of war with humility,
and that's so critical.
So in Ephesians four, one through three, Paul exhorts us,
he says, I urge you to walk in a manner worthy
of the calling to which he have been called with all
humility and gentleness, with patience, bearing
with one another in love, eager to maintain the unity
of the spirit and the bond of peace.
And so what I'm going to do tonight,
I'm gonna follow John's structure from Sunday,
but we'll put on our scuba gear
and we'll sit on the back of the boat
and we'll fall backward into the water,
and we'll dive deep into some of these points
that he talked about on Sunday.
We probably can't cover everything tonight, and that's okay.
So let's bow our heads and let's pray together.
Father, we, uh, we see you as God Almighty,
and this is your church, Jesus.
You haven't given any other group
of people the higher honor
or privilege than to call us your body.
Give us your wisdom. Help us to love your church,
to be more committed to it.
Speak to us through your word tonight.
It's in Jesus name we pray. Amen. All right.
So John's first question on
Sunday was this, what is the church?
Well, ecclesiology again is, uh, what attempts
to answer this question.
And, uh, this is the doctrine of the church.
And it comes from the Greek word, uh, ecclesia,
which John showed us means called out ones.
We are ones who are called out. We are separate.
And there's a bright line through us, through the church
that marks us off from the rest of the world.
Also, Peter says in one Peter two 11, he says, beloved,
I urge you as sojourners in exiles
to abstain from the passions of the flesh,
which wage war against your soul.
So we're in this strange in between, though,
where we're both in the world, but not of this world.
We're residents here.
We clearly live here and we work here,
but yet, like Peter says, we're also sojourners.
We're also exiles. We're aliens in this world.
So we're living in the already and the not yet.
And this is what the church straddles until he comes again.
So what is the church?
Well, Paul writes to Timothy instructions in one Timothy
three 14 through 16, that he may know
how one ought to behave in the household of God,
which is the Church of the Living God, a pillar
and buttress of the truth.
Great indeed, we confess, is the mystery of godliness.
He was manifested in the flesh.
He was vindicated by the spirit, seen by angels proclaimed
among the nations, believed on in the world,
taken up in glory.
And that is beautiful. John mentioned it.
This church that Paul is referring
to in this passage is the invisible church
or the universal church.
It's the big C church.
And, and people often short circuit this,
and they, they somehow think
that the big C church is just the churches
around the world right now.
And that's, that's okay,
but let's, let's understand this more completely.
The universal Church is all genuine believers
across all of history,
and everyone in the future who will believe.
So we're talking about Abraham here. This is Paul.
This is, this is Augustine, this is John Calvin,
this is Edwards.
This is Whitfield, the Wesley brothers, Spurgeon,
Sproul, you and me, God willing.
And this is also God willing, again, you're yet to come.
Great, great grandkids. That is the universal church.
So we have this invisible universal church there,
but there's also what we call the visible church
or the local church.
And in this passage that we just read
through the local church is the church that Paul is writing
to in that whole letter to Ephesus,
the church in Ephesus.
The local church is a local expression of the visible
of the universal church.
It's a local expression,
and we would describe it loosely
as a subset, but guess what?
If we want to get down to the brass tacks,
it's not technically a subset.
The local church uses membership to determine who's in
and who's out.
And we rely on what's called a credible confession of faith,
a credible confession of faith
to determine if you can be a member
or not, just like many churches do.
So the the issue there though is can we, can the elders,
can those who we've designated to interview
possible member candidates, do we know for certain
that you're a genuine believer?
No, we can't know that. Only God knows hearts.
We don't know hearts.
So the visible church can in fact include
believers and
non-believers, unwittingly.
And that's why the membership process is to, is so important
that it be complete as much as possible.
So if this were a Venn diagram,
the universal church is this huge circle, all believers,
all time, past, present, future.
And the visible church is this smaller circle
that isn't totally contained in the larger circle.
There's some overlap there,
because not everyone in,
not every member in a local church is a genuine believer.
And so that means in this room,
even tonight, this is Wednesday night.
You're the core, the core few, the essentials,
the the truly committed among you that even in this room,
there are seats that are filled
by unbelievers here potentially.
And that's a sobering thought,
but that's a great launch point for us.
The, the church is connected at the hip with the gospel,
and we see this beautiful picture of the mystery of God
in the passage.
We just read this gospel that's available, this mystery,
this gospel that's available to Jew and Gentile alike.
And it's right there next to this description of the church
as the, the pillar and buttress of the truth.
The gospel is the door and the substance of the church.
And you can't separate the church from the gospel.
So have you ever heard the saying,
you can take the gospel out of the church, but, but you can,
but you can, you can't take the church out of the gospel.
You've, you've never heard
that saying, because it's not true.
Okay? It's not true. It's not a saying at all since the
gospel is the door to our understanding of the church.
Well, what is it? Is this idea
that we were created in the image of God,
but we displeased him.
We dishonored him, we sinned against him,
this holy God of the universe.
But in his mercy
and the great love with which he loved us,
he sent his son Jesus
to live the perfect life that we couldn't live.
And he humbled himself to the point of death,
even death on a cross,
he rose again, victorious over death so that anyone
who believes in him, who calls him Lord,
has eternal life with him.
And we'll one day see him face
to face in supreme.
No more tears, no more pain, no, uh,
to His glory, right?
And so in this, uh, time on Sunday,
John also described the metaphors of the church.
We see it in this passage we just read.
We saw a metaphor of the household of God.
Uh, the church is a temple.
Uh, we're God's people, we're his flock.
But then we get to this, this body of Christ metaphor
that we see in one Corinthians 12.
So richly, we see Christ as the head.
And this is incredible.
The church is the only thing in the universe
with this privilege
and the honor of being called the body of Christ.
We are the body of Christ under his headship.
Do you see what great an honor that is?
So one of John's questions
on Sunday was this, what is the structure?
What is the structure of the church?
There are many structures of the church,
is the, is the short answer.
But within the Baptist world, we, uh, see often
the structure of senior pastor and a deacon board.
I grew up in a structure like that.
Uh, Henderson Hills was like this until the, the nineties.
So why, why is our,
and John talked at length about this, why, you know how we,
we have a plurality of elders and we have deacons.
We see those two offices in scripture.
We see that in several place.
We see it very clearly in Philippians one, one.
But why, why is our structure considered elder led?
Elder led? So one Timothy three, one
through 13 talks about that.
And I, I won't reread all of that.
We have limited time tonight.
We, we talked about that at length on Sunday.
But, uh, again, much of what we, much of how we,
uh, lead the church
and govern the church, we search the scriptures
desperately for his wisdom in how to do our church
and how to lead the church
and how, how to care for the church.
And we see in scripture this plurality of elders
that leads feeds, cares for and protects the church.
So we're sre we're squeezing as much info
as we can out of scripture.
And there's also not a lot
else in scripture that we can follow.
So there's not a lot there,
but it's clear there are two distinct offices,
elders and deacons.
So that's a din that's a distinction.
This, this ecclesiology of our church versus,
say the Catholic church.
A Catholic structure is, is very complex,
very ornate, I would say.
And it's informed by scripture
and tradition together.
But we see that scripture prescribes a much simpler
structure, one with a plurality of elders who lead feed care
for and protect the church.
And we also see the office of Deacon who are,
as John said on Sunday, the leading servants of the church.
Well, let's, let's dive in a little bit deeper.
How specifically is Henderson Hills governed?
Well, we see how Henderson Hills governed
as an elder led yet congregationally
governed church.
This is Congregationalism Congregationalism.
So the elders lead the church give
with their God-given authority,
but under the authority of Christ
and his word, the congregation has the final
human authority within Henderson Hills.
So our church participation in the Baptist
Convention is voluntary.
We, we are part of that.
And each church within the convention that associates
with the convention has autonomy.
And we don't have the central governing authority.
But the final human authority at Henderson Hills is vested
within the members.
Again, that's elder led congregationally governed,
and there's biblical support for that.
We see that in Matthew 16. We see that in Matthew 18.
We see that in one Corinthians five, acts six, acts 13.
Let me read for you, Matthew 18, 15 through 18.
You're very familiar with this passage.
If you're brother sins against you, go
and tell him his fault between you and him alone.
If he listens to you, you have gained your brother.
But if he does not listen, take one
or two others along with you,
that every charge may be established by the evidence of two
or three witnesses.
If he refuses to listen to them, tell it to the church.
And if he refuses to listen even to the church, let him be
to a, to you as a gentile and a tax collector.
Truly, I say to you, whatever you bind on earth shall be
bound in heaven, and whatever you loose on
earth shall be loose in heaven.
So there's something major to see there,
that it's the church, the members, the people
that have the final authority in this case,
to excommunicate someone.
That final verse there where it says, um,
whatever you loose on earth shall be loose in heaven,
bind on, uh, bind on earth bound in heaven.
It's talking about church discipline there, okay?
It's not talking about binding the devil
and things like that, but it's talking about
church discipline.
So the members have the final authority
to excommunicate someone, okay,
to disallow somebody from,
from the congregation, from the body.
So, uh, certainly we, uh, we practice church discipline.
That's a much wider topic.
We're open for questions for that later.
Uh, we have, uh, different ways of handling that, um,
some very biblically informed ways of handling that.
Uh, we have these terms, xco, ea and X communication.
Uh, we, we we're happy to talk with you about that,
if you want to talk, uh, hear more about
that in the q and a later.
So again, I just wanna reiterate,
we're elder led congregational church.
And this is in contrast to churches
where elders make the final decision
where the buck stops with the elders.
That's not us. That's a model called elder ruled.
Elder ruled, which I believe most churches
who uphold this, I could be wrong.
Uh, certainly Joe
and Aaron can speak to this as they come up here,
but I believe most, most churches who
who are elder ruled tend to be, um, other reformed churches,
presbyterian churches, uh, churches like that.
Um, uh, so most are elder ruled as, as opposed to elder led.
So we are elder led decon, conserved,
congregationally ruled.
So that's right. Uh,
so we're talking about
membership here just a little bit here.
Uh, as a member here, you have a measure of authority.
So don't, don't, uh, don't not see that.
That's a, that's an amazing privilege. That's a benefit.
And you may even see that as a responsibility.
It is a responsibility.
You have the, you have several responsibilities when you
become a member at Henderson Hills.
Probably more responsibilities than at most churches.
So you have the ability to select, rebuke,
and dismiss the lead teaching pastor.
You can select, rebuke, dismiss deacons,
and do the same with elders.
You can select full-time, pastoral staff members.
These are, you'll, you'll see that from time
to time when they come on stage.
And, and these are called positions.
You vote for these called pastoral positions.
You make major decisions alongside us, uh, related
to building and facility issues.
You get to approve financial budgets here at Henderson,
which we're just about to launch into that very, very soon.
So be looking forward to that.
You get to, uh, vote on the amending of bylaws,
and you also get to speak into other matter matters
that the Elder, elder Council, uh, would like
to have your advice on and counsel on.
You have additional responsibilities also, as members.
You, you are called to live holy lives.
How you are is a reflection of the church
and ultimately a reflection on Christ himself.
That's a weighty responsibility.
You have the responsibility to have meaningful
relationships with one another.
And, and you also have this responsibility
to regularly attend church.
Some churches have, uh, enact discipline on members
who, uh, don't attend.
Okay? So, so it's a, it's a big deal that you attend church.
It's an important part.
So that's a brief bit on our structure,
a little bit more clarity, a little bit more depth on
what John spoke of on Sunday.
I hope that's helpful to you.
So that brings us now to the meat of the night.
What makes a church a church,
what makes a church a church,
versus people hanging out together
and having a Bible study together.
So John described it as three markers.
Essentially, he said it as worshiping God,
nurturing believers, and living scent.
And that's absolutely right. That's absolutely right.
That encompasses what makes a church a church.
A church is a gathering of believers who worship God.
This is a place that nurtures our faith,
and it lives to be a means
of accomplishing God's mission in the world.
But let's, let's, for the purpose of tonight,
expand this understanding a little wider.
Let's cast a wider net, more detailed net here.
So let's hear what some theologians have
to say about this question of what makes a church a church.
So if we were to have John Calvin here
and Martin Luther here, I would say,
what makes a church a church?
And this is what they would say.
So John, John Calvin, you know him.
He's the French reformer
and, uh, lawyer who identified two things
that make a church a church.
Calvin said, wherever we see the word of God
purely preached and heard,
and the sacraments, which are the Lord's Supper and baptism,
and where we see the, the sacraments administered according
to Christ's institution, there it is not
to be doubted A church of God exists.
If Luther was asked the question right here, he,
he defined the church as the congregation
of saints in which the gospel is rightly taught
and the sacraments rightly administered.
So here we see two things that make a church, a church,
God's word rightly preached,
and the practice of the sacraments,
or what we would call here ordinances, that's
what makes a church a church.
All that to say, though, is if you ask any theologian
or church leader what makes a church a church,
you'd probably get some different answers.
But we're all saying essentially the same thing, in which,
which, and I've attempted to boil down that for you tonight.
So we'll make it through this together.
We'll examine each of these points as, uh, signposts.
And each of these signposts taken together are ones
that you can kind of walk by and understand.
Yeah, this is a church.
This is a church signposts number
zero, signpost number zero of what makes a church a church
is that it is doxological.
It is doxological.
And I have this as signpost zero since this precedes
and permeates every other signpost.
Doxological comes from this root doxology, the Greek word,
do two parts, dosa,
which means glory or praise,
and Lagos, which means a speaking
or a word.
So if we are doxological, we are praising him,
speaking of his glory, we are speaking of his glory.
When we are doxological, churches are oriented
to glorify God, first
and foremost, to rightly give him the honor
and glory, do his name above all else.
We see this crystallized in the Westminster Shorter
catechism, which asks,
what is the chief end of man?
Which says, what? I know some of you know this.
What does that say? Does
anybody know what, what?
The Westminster shorter catechism question one asks,
call less, okay, I'll tell you, I'll tell you.
It says To glorify God and enjoy him forever.
That is our purpose. It's to, to, to glorify God
and enjoy him forever.
Romans 1136 says, for from him and through him
and to him are all things to him
be glory forever and ever.
Amen. For to give him glory.
One Corinthians 10 31 says, so whether you eat or drink,
or whatever you do, do all to the glory of God,
including how you do church.
One Peter two, nine through 11 says,
but you are a chosen race, a royal priesthood of people
for his own possession,
that you may proclaim the excellencies of him
who called you out of darkness and into his marvelous light.
Once you are not a people, but now you're God's people.
Once you had not received mercy,
but now you have received mercies, we are
to proclaim the excellencies of him
who called us outta darkness into his light.
That is to give him glory.
Philippians four, four says,
rejoice in the, in the Lord, always.
And again, I say, rejoice all glory
to him, all glory to him.
Amen. Our joy is welded
to his glory.
And you can't separate the two.
Part of what makes a church a church is that it is first
and foremost doxological.
It is His glory that we speak of.
And that leads us to signpost. Number one.
Calvin and Luther were aren't alone in that.
They pegged the right preaching of God's word as the first
and foremost concrete qualifier of
what constitutes a church.
First Timothy four 13, Paul says, to devote yourselves
to the public reading of scripture,
to exhortation, to teaching.
And we at Henderson Hills, we have a deep conviction
regarding the authority, the sufficiency, the,
the inerrancy, the clarity of God's word.
It is our anchoring truth. We say here, and you know what?
That is exactly, exactly
what we heard 15 years ago when we visited 15 years ago,
in that back row of seats, that's what we heard.
So scripture as the foundation of our faith,
it shapes our beliefs, it guides our actions.
It follows then that rightly preaching God's word
must be central to the life and the health of the church.
An expository preaching is particularly vital
because it adheres most faithfully
to this biblical commitment.
What is expository preaching? What is expository preaching?
In expository preaching, the pastor takes a specific passage
of scripture, systematically unpacks the meaning,
the relevance, the application.
And one way to say it is for how
to define expository preaching.
The point of the passage is the point of the message.
And so this, this type of preaching,
expository preaching ensures
that we're seeing the full scope of God's word week
after week, and it is exposing God's word to us.
And it guards against avoiding difficult passages
or allowing us to focus on our, our favorite
personal topics, which we all want to do,
but it guards against that.
You know, you, you can, you can hear when it's not
expository preaching, can't you?
You can hear it. You can hear when somebody has an axe
to grind their, they're using scripture to advance their,
their own agenda or trying
to reinforce their political bent, can't you?
You can hear it. So the deciding factor
that causes some preachers to be effective
and others ineffective, is their confidence in the power
of God's word.
Paul Exhorts Timothy in two Timothy four, one, he says,
I charge you in the presence of God
and of Christ Jesus who is to judge the living and the dead.
And by his appearing
and his kingdom, preach the word, be ready in season, out
of season, reprove rebuke exhort with complete patience
and teaching for the time is coming when people will not
endure sound teaching, but have,
but having itching ears, they'll accumulate
for themselves teachers to suit their own passions
and will turn away from listening to the truth
and wander off and to myths.
Is topical preaching? Okay, it's topic preaching.
Okay, well, we favor expository preaching, certainly,
but did you know that in our history, uh,
we've had topical series?
We think that's okay. We think that's okay, can be argued
that you can do topical exposition,
but I think that's an argument for another day.
We certainly favor expository preaching.
Does expository preaching equal verse by verse preaching?
No, not necessarily.
If you're preaching what the passage is saying,
and you're not bringing your own meaning to the text,
that is expository,
and verse by verse is a type of expository preaching.
So we've seen now that part of
what makes a church a church is
that it is fundamentally doxological speaks of his glory,
and also that it rightly preaches the word of God.
Signpost Number two,
what makes a church a church is the practice
of the ordinances.
So what is an ordinance?
An ordinance are things or is a thing that Jesus ordained
or instituted or commanded the church to do.
And he ordered the church to do two things,
baptize and to take the Lord's supper together.
And these ordinances are signs of the gospel made visible
baptism we see as our union
and Christ's death, burial, resurrection,
and the Lord's Supper is our participation in
and remembrance of his broken body and his blood.
And baptism is what we would say is an initiating ordinance.
It's where we publicly profess
and express our fellowship with Christ.
And we see his command
of baptize in Matthew 11, 19 through 20.
You know, this passage, go
therefore make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father and of the Son,
and of the Holy Spirit teaching them
to observe all that I've commanded you.
And behold, I'm with you always to the end of this age.
We see in scripture that baptism is only for people
who are believers, for those who have been saved.
And we see that saved people should be baptized.
We understand scripture to in instructs
that we only baptize those who as best we can tell,
have been saved again,
who have a credible profession of faith.
And we also believe that this, that since this is a normal
expected initiation step into Christian discipleship,
that church membership is for those who have been baptized.
So part of what makes a church a church is that it is
that it is doxological.
It rightly preaches God's word,
and it regularly practices the ordinances of baptism
and the Lord's Supper signpost.
Number three, what makes a church a church is
that it is Lago centric.
Lago centric, the way John said it on Sunday is that it,
that a church is truth
and Christ based, absolutely a Christian Church,
is necessarily oriented around the truth of Christ,
around his gospel, around the word of God.
And so what do we mean by laga centric?
Or we saw the word doxology earlier, dosa glory
and, uh, loggy speaking or word.
So log Lago centric just means word centered. Word centered.
And when we meet word centered,
we meet it in a couple different senses.
One in which the cr, uh, Christ is the word incarnate,
John one, we see that.
And also the inspired word of God, scripture,
we see in scripture that Christ is the
cornerstone of the church.
You remember the scene in Acts, acts four, when Peter
and John are arrested, they're put
before the Sanhedrin council.
And Peter boldly proclaims to this council.
He says, so boldly says this, Jesus is the stone
that was rejected by you, the builders,
which has become the cornerstone.
And there is salvation in no one else.
And there is no other name under heaven given among men
by which we must be saved.
If Jesus is the cornerstone of the church,
if he grounded it, if he created it, if he was foundational
for it, Matthew 16, he says, I will build my church
if he's all of that.
If there is salvation under no other name under heaven,
then it makes sense that we would be Christ centered,
that we would be gospel centered,
that we would be word centered.
So part of what makes a church a church is
that it is doxological.
It rightly preaches God's word. It practices the ordinances.
And it is logo centric.
It is word centric signpost number four,
we've already talked some about this,
so I won't belabor this one too much.
But what makes a church a church is that there is
meaningful membership, meaningful membership,
not a weak membership that gives false assurance
of salvation to people within the church.
It's a dangerous thing.
But we see church membership as a vital expression
of a believer's commitment to a local body of believers.
And so we see this as a biblical model
that is an identifiable covenantal community
within our church.
And we saw this earlier,
but you being a member have a commitment
to the church, as the church does to you.
And all of this is designed to foster accountability,
discipline, pastoral care illustrates a testimony of faith
to an unbelieving world that so desperately needs Jesus.
So part of what makes a church is that it is doxological
rightly preaches God's word.
It practices the ordinances.
It is logo centric, and it has meaningful membership.
The last signpost we'll talk about we heard on Sunday is
that the church is sent.
The church is sent. We are on mission.
We are evangelistic stick. Matthew 28, 19 through 20.
We've already read this, but we are to go make disciples
of all nations.
John 20 says, as the Father has sent me, so I'm sending you,
and this is what we mean by living sent.
We have been instructed by God himself, by Christ himself,
to go and make disciples of all nations
to be witnesses locally and globally.
So I am thankful for this community of believers, this,
this church of Jesus Christ
that he has providentially planted me and my family in.
I'm thankful for you.
You know, there's, in these 15 years,
there have been tough things that we've walked
through my family, and I cannot imagine
life without you.
So as I've worked through this,
I'm reminded of the incredible privilege
and the responsibility that we hold as members of
this body, Henderson Hills.
We are not just brought together by shared belief,
but by God himself to reflect his glory.
What makes a church a church?
It upholds the glory of God
through the preaching of his word.
It's demonstrated through his ordinances.
It radiates outward through his mission in the world.
And we have a part of that praise God.
The church is to be a pillar
and a buttress of the truth in a world that needs it,
it needs the gospel.
It needs to be saved.
So I'll close with this passage from Hebrews
10 23 to 25.
Excuse me. Let us hold fast.
The confession of our hope without wavering for he
who promised is faithful.
And let us consider how to stir up one another to love
and good works, not neg, not neglecting to meet together
as is the habit of some, but encouraging one another
and all the more as you see the day drawing near.
Praise God. Well, now this is the moment of the,
of our night together where we get to field q and a.
If you're so interested to ask any questions, the, the, uh,
it'll have my brothers come up here.
Uh, Joe and Aaron, they're gonna help me tonight.
Um, but this gives you an opportunity.
The, the doctrine of the church
ecclesiology is an incredibly dipped, uh, uh,
deep doctrine.
And, uh, so you may have an infinite number of questions.
We, we'd love to answer your questions if you have them.
We have two mics set up if you'd like.
And, uh, if we have nobody, we have some questions
that we could, we ask each other.
Thanks, Ryan. Thanks Ryan.
Yeah, thank you, Joe.
I'm so honored to sit where John Calvin used to sit.
Yeah, it's Unbelievable.
Or is this Martin Luther? Yeah,
This is Luther. Oh, this
is Luther. This here. Well, at least we have two
Smart people up here.
Yes. Okay. I have a quick question
and I haven't really developed it fully.
So can you kind of expound on
expo expositional preaching?
Because what I heard was it just takes the verse
and kind of unpacks it.
And so how do you guard against taking it out of context?
Because I mean, even secular society takes verses
and just uses it for their own benefit when they just used
that verse instead of looking at the whole
why it was written and who it was written to
and what was going on at the time.
So could you explain, kind
of explain that a little bit more?
Yeah. We left you what, what's your name? Sorry. It's
Okay. Susan Bain.
Susan, thank you for your question.
That's a really good question.
So, uh,
so let's talk about expositional expository preaching.
What is it? What, what is that?
Um, uh, what I've come to understand as it relates
to expository preaching,
these guys can speak into it better than I can,
but what, what I've come
to learn about expository preaching is everybody has their
own view of it.
And so, um, the way that I see it
is expository preaching is understanding.
Uh, a phrase that I've heard is that you,
you bleed over the passage.
You pour out your heart and your soul. You seek God.
You pray, God show, show me Holy Spirit,
illuminate this passage to me as you're studying
to preach this passage.
And so, uh, everything
that you do in your preparation is toward
understanding the context.
What is the original audience?
What is the historical context?
Understanding the whole of the, of the chapter, the whole
of the book, the whole of the Bible.
There's biblical theology, which is a study
of the whole narrative theology of all of scripture.
How does this, how does this passage
fit into all of scripture?
And, uh, you do your best to find what is the main point
of this passage, given everything that you see there.
And so you pour over it by the spirit's, help, um,
to try and understand those things.
You know, at Charles Simeon Trust, uh, is a workshop
that many of us have done.
And in that workshop, it teaches you
to find the line of scripture.
And when you find the line of scripture, you're finding the,
the gold vein that runs
through the passage you're looking at.
And you stick to that.
And you, you, you, you preach it to other people
and you say, am I sticking to that line of scripture,
that gold vein of scripture?
So there, there's a lot of things that you can do there.
These, these guys can speak more into that certainly,
but that's, that's what we're all keeping our minds tuned to
as we're trying to be faithful to his word.
I would just say that, uh, I think simply
expositional preaching is exposing
the meaning of the passage.
Again, in context, really loved what you said,
but, uh, think of it as exposing what God has for us in
that passage in the context of what was meant
to the people for whom it was written.
Aaron can probably get a little more detailed on that.
No, that's well said.
And a lot of pastors will bring their own opinions,
their own preferences, their own, uh, ideas
to the scripture and try to twist it
and make it fit what they want, the narrative they want to,
to, to preach versus expository.
We wanna allow the scriptures to drive the message.
And so we filter all of our thoughts and opinions
and preferences through the scriptures rather than the other
way around filtering the scriptures
through our thoughts and opinions.
So expository, again, allowing the, the heart
of the message, the, the, the passage
to be the message that goes out.
I think Ryan said it really well.
Good question. Thank you. And it's interesting
because there is a, uh, a distinction
because, um, when we preach about something like salvation,
that's winds up being a topical, uh, subject to preach on.
So there are times when you do, uh, preach topically, uh,
but you still have to be true to the golden vein,
if you will, uh, in the storyline of scripture, uh,
systematic theology is by definition topical.
So we're not saying that topical is bad, uh,
but, uh, deep dive expositionally into a passage, uh,
is what we prefer.
Yeah, good question. Good question.
Knee. How,
Hi. Um,
so I come from a charismatic church.
I've only been a Baptist for about five years.
So I guess my question is,
when I'm having these conversations with my family, I mean,
we believe in the big rocks, which is revelation, salvation,
the trinity, all of the stuff that we spoke about,
but some of these little rocks we go back and forth on.
An example is when John said last week
that some churches believe
that one should become a believer.
You get baptized with the Holy Spirit
and everybody speaks in tongues.
Whilst we in Henderson Hills believe that it's a gift
and some people can speak in it.
So I guess my question is, what should be the goal
of these conversations?
Should a goal be to win them over to become Baptist?
Or we should just agree
to disagree when we have these conversations?
Thank you,
Nee, that's a great question.
So what, uh, as it relates to secondary,
secondary issues within the church and,
and, uh, when we're talking to people that we love, uh,
is our goal to win them over, uh, what is the goal there?
And that's the question.
Um, I will, I will say from a personal story standpoint,
my, my parents, both my dad
and my mom met in seventh grade in Ecuador as,
uh, missionary kids.
And, um, I won't say the, the, the denomination they went
with, and it could have been the people
that they were there with.
But because my mom as a third grader, as a fourth grader,
as a fifth grader, sixth grader, as she was there, uh,
was tremendously hurt by
people arguing for the secondary issues,
like speaking in tongues like you just mentioned me.
It's a really good example
because they believed my mom
to not be a Christian because she didn't speak in tongues.
So she was incredibly hurt
by the church at that point in time.
And so, uh, certainly we don't want to use secondary issues
to, to bludgeon other people
and to hurt people and things like that.
So what is the goal as we discuss secondary issues?
Um, I think the goal would be toward
unity, certainly.
Uh, and then, and then also toward, you know,
as illuminating as much that we see in scripture as possible
with these other believers.
But it's, it's not anything that I think that we should
hit them over the head with, right?
There's, there's a gentleness aspect to it.
There's a humility, a gentleness, patience.
We bear with them. Uh,
we bear with the failings of the weak.
If we, if we see it as a failing of, of, of on their part,
that, that, uh, they don't see scripture
that seems to be clear.
Uh, we, we bear with them in that.
That's, that's what I would say.
I don't know if you guys have
anything additional to say about that.
Great answer. Yeah, I would agree.
Tolerance is bearing with their belief
if they can, if they love the Lord Jesus Christ.
And salvation is, is the primary
unifying factor there.
There's those second tier issues.
We can agree to disagree on a lot of those and, and,
and still walk together in unity in some ways.
Yeah, I think that's again, the key, uh,
agree on the big rocks, the secondary issues, uh,
walk alongside them, uh, love them.
Uh, explain where you're at,
but don't let it divide you, uh, in your fellowship,
in your, in your walk with Christ.
Don't let it become, uh, a barrier
to your fellowship in Christ.
Now, as you get, uh, further into it
and as you determine how you worship,
those do become important.
'cause that, that's what we're talking about, ecclesiology.
They're, they're, they're secondary,
but they're also important.
But don't let it diminish your love for that person.
So I think tolerance was a great point.
Yeah. Again, as a spoiler for Sunday, we're,
we're talking about reformed theology on Sunday, which I,
which I would probably say is one of the most divisive
of the secondary issues.
Um, and so that's another area where people need
to understand to be, uh, humble in their approach
and gentle in their approach.
Oftentimes the, the two, the two dominant camps,
there can be pretty, uh, heels in the ground
and, uh, that that's hurtful to the witness
of Christ to other people.
So, any other questions?
Got a question. Um,
so all my life I've grown up in a church that is led
by just one man
and coming to Henderson Hills
where it's being led by elders.
So I know with the one month church,
usually he has the final say, and then he does everything.
Can you just shed a little light on some of the struggles
that comes with, I mean, I know it's not perfect,
but like being an elder led church,
when you guys disagree on stuff, how do you come to that,
uh, consensus or like agreement?
Because I know there's no one person who has the finances.
So how do you kinda like,
resolve when there's disagreements there?
That's a good question. So question is
senior pastor led churches, there's one decision maker,
elder led churches, elder rule churches, in some cases, uh,
uh, decisions are made by a plurality of elders.
So how does that look like in practice?
And, um, I've only been a part of the council for two years,
um, so I can only share a sliver of my view into that.
But, uh, what I've, what I've really appreciated in
witnessing these brothers on the council,
and I've learned so much from them, is we,
we talk about it all the time.
This Ephesians four, humility and gentleness and patience.
There's a, there's a, a deference, there's a, there's a,
a revered, there's a respect among the council,
among the other elders that
respects differing viewpoints
that lets differing viewpoints come up.
And, uh, we decide together.
In some cases we vote
and, uh, somebody says, well, I think A and,
and the rest say B.
And, uh, we decide differently.
But when we vote, we walk outta that room, uh,
every time we walk outta that room in unity,
singing the same tune.
And so, uh, coming to decisions is naturally,
as you would expect among, among a plurality of elders,
a slower thing than if it was a senior pastor
just making a decision.
It's a slower thing, but,
but we would say that it's a God ordained,
slowing mechanism.
If he didn't, if he didn't want the church to be led
by plurality of elders, he wouldn't have in scripture.
Every single time he mentions, um, church leadership,
it's always in the plural, right?
And so I think that it, that it is a slowing mechanism
is a means it is a divine slowing mechanism.
It kind of keeps tempers in check
and keeps, uh, keeps things oriented toward wisdom.
Uh, yeah, I would just say that, uh,
many times we've gone in with an opinion about
what should happen, but as we, uh, defer to the others,
uh, what happens is, is we believe, uh,
that, uh, the Holy Spirit leads us to, uh,
what his preference would be on a particular issue.
And, uh, very often it's, uh, not similar
to anybody's in particular,
or not, not perfect line up
with anybody's particular idea as they went in.
I think that's the value of the plurality of elders is, um,
having many counselors, uh, bring wiser decisions,
even if they're a bit slower, we believe,
I thought you were gonna say we never disagree.
I did not say that. That's
A good answer. Yeah. In
Acts 15, it talks about this idea of it,
it seemed good to the Holy Spirit and to us.
And so there's this idea of what Joe is speaking of,
that we're, we're seeking the Lord, we're asking the,
the Spirit to, um, to show us.
And so we, we eagerly seek, seek his wisdom
as we make decisions.
Believe it or not, elders have blind spots.
And when there's more than one,
sometimes the blind spots get, can get exposed.
And as we come together humbly,
we can hopefully find the best, best solution.
Okay. Ryan, I had a quick question.
You didn't ask this at the very first,
but I grew up Methodist.
Okay. And, um, you know, when I was saved, I was sprinkled.
And when I got to, um, college, I started, uh,
attending a Baptist church
and I realized that I needed to follow Christ example
and, um, be immersed.
And, um, it, um, when we have our,
the Lord's Supper, it used to be that I know that they
would say, if you have been baptized,
you can take the Lord's Supper.
And I haven't really heard that lately,
and I didn't know if that was, uh, something that our church
observed that you needed to be baptized
before you took the Lord's Supper.
So that's,
That's a good question.
I'm sorry, what's your name? I can't,
I can't see very well at all. I apologize.
Um, uh, Laurie Cunningham.
Laurie. Uh, well, thank you, Laurie. Appreciate that.
Um, I could maybe speak into this some, uh, again,
as we talk about the ordinances that, that Jesus
gave us, uh, we see baptism
and we see, um, the Lord's Supper.
And so the, the question is,
can you take the Lord's supper without having been baptized?
Or is that, is that something that we would support?
Is that a good, good recap of the, of the question? Okay.
Uh, the way that we talk about baptism is, again, it's kind
of like this, this initiating ordinance.
It's this, it's this sign that we are now a part
of the body of Christ.
And so then the, the Lord's Supper ends up being described
as this continuing, this continuing ordinance that says,
we are in fellowship with Christ, with other believers,
uh, in this church.
And so, uh, to me, I, I, I think that we, I think
that we understand it to be, you need to be
a baptized believer to partake in the, in the Lord's supper.
I, I could be wrong. Am I wrong, Joe?
Uh, you're not wrong.
Uh, I, I think the way that it's been characterized,
and as you can see, we don't necessarily always agree,
even though we love and respect each other.
Uh, and we did say that at one time, uh,
from the, from the platform.
And one of the things that we value is, uh,
we call it simple, simple referenda.
And that is, as we dig deeper,
uh, we learn more.
Uh, so, uh,
we, and and again, it's just, it's another perspective,
but where we are today is we don't say
that only baptized believers can come to the,
to the Lord's table table.
Um, by definition, baptism will come, should come
after salvation, and it is initiatory, but,
and it is a, uh,
an act which shows your, uh,
obedience and fidelity to Christ.
So it is a condition of church membership.
Uh, but we haven't seen in scripture that it's a condition
for taking the Lord's Supper.
So we don't say that anymore.
We say, if you're a believer in Christ, you're welcome
to the Lord's table.
So that, that's where we are currently. And Aaron,
And agree with of Those, both of I misstated there.
I agree with both of those.
And I think what Ryan was trying to say is, ideally
we would, we would like for you to be baptized first
and then do the Lord's Supper.
But here's the thing, in the New Testament,
they would've gotten baptized immediately after salvation.
So this was never a question.
Everybody who took the Lord's Supper would've been baptized.
'cause you see, immediately they get saved,
immediately they get baptized.
So, but the problem we have today is somebody gets saved
and they schedule their baptism for two months from today,
and we have the Lord's Supper twice
before they get baptized, can they take the Lord's supper?
And we've been asked that before, particularly with kids.
Kids get saved. We want the whole family
to be here for their baptism.
It's two months down the road.
But we've had the Lord's Supper twice, so we get asked,
can my son have the Lord's Supper?
Well, the answer to that is, that's up to you mom and dad.
But we like to tell them, we would prefer
that you would be baptized first out of obedience.
And then, but we can't.
There's, as Joe said, there's no verse that we can point to
that says, no, you cannot.
Um, if they're saved, they can have the Lord's Supper.
We've got their baptism scheduled.
You know, in our modern structure,
we've kind of created this problem.
But I don't think that was a problem in the New Testament.
So thank you, Lord. Hopefully that makes sense.
So if we're airing, it may be
that we don't baptize people immediately,
but then that's another discussion to have
Some churches, as soon as you get saved, they'll,
they'll dunk you on the stage, right?
Because they don't want, they don't want
that confusion there.
So we've never done that here.
Good question. Good question, Sherry.
Hey, my question, um, might be just terminology,
but, um, as far as ordinances, I've always heard
marriage referred to as an ordinance.
Is that true?
Or how do we phrase that at, at Henderson?
I've never heard that. So that's new to me.
Question. Marriage as an ordinance
Is marriage as an ordinance of the church.
Okay.
Yeah. I, I haven't heard that either.
I know that, um, the Catholic church has a whole list
of sacraments.
I'm not sure if that's on their list of sacraments. It is.
Okay. So maybe that's where that comes from.
Um, and then if you're curious, the language
of sacrament versus ordinance, um,
for all intents and purposes, you can kind
of consider them the same thing.
Uh, but there, there was a distancing of, uh,
away from the word sacrament, Ackerman, around the time
of the reformation, uh, just
because of its connection to the,
to the Catholic church. And so
It's all Martin Luther's fault. Yeah.
Martin, yeah. Thank you.
Sherry. Any other questions?
Probably should, probably, it's almost time.
Okay. We got four more minutes.
Alright. Thank you all.
Yeah, thank you all very much.
Well, let's go ahead and pray and we'll get on outta here.
Father, we thank you for tonight.
Thank you for my brothers up here.
Joe and Aaron, thank you
for the church body that's before us.
Thank you for this fellowship that we share together.
We're so blessed and honored to be able
to serve alongside everybody here.
Um, Jesus, you love your church.
Um, there is no other institution that you call your body
and we don't take that lightly.
Um, so God help us to serve in the unique giftings
that you've given to each of us.
Um, there is no part of the body
that is less valuable than any other part.
And so, God, we pray that you would use us,
use everybody individually in this church to serve the body.
We need them. But God, let us also revel in your grace
that you've shown to us, your great mercy
and your grace that you've shown to us.
That it is by grace that we have been saved.
So we are so thankful for Jesus, for his sacrifice
for us on the cross, that he would, um,
that he would die on the cross for our sins,
for, for even us.
So God, we pray that you would preserve your church,
that you would use us in your church
to accomplish your mission in, in the world, so
that others would come to know you.
Jesus, we love you. We trust you.
It's in Jesus' name we pray. Amen. Thank you all.